[Musique]
bonsoir à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture tout de
suite le sommaire jusqu'au 21 février le
prix smile en cours accueillent
l'exposition scenocosme elle permet au
public de découvrir quatre oeuvres
hybrides entre le monde vivant qu'est la
technologie l'art contemporain à
l'honneur à versailles sculptures
tableaux gravures près 250 oeuvres ont
investi le carré à la farine à
l'occasion de la quatrième ligne à
versailles m ils sont étudiants
ingénieurs mais aussi comédien focus
dans cette émission sur le club théâtre
de l'estaca à montigny le bretonneux le
30 janvier prochain et présenteront au
public leur pièce match à domicile
rencontre imaginaire light contact ou
encore en fonal yom
voici les noms de ces installations
interactives qui ont pris place au
prisme à elancourt des oeuvres qui
permettent au public d'explorer les
capacités qu'offrent les technologies de
manière assez particulière comme vous
allez le découvrir
cet arbuste qui réagit au contact humain
à l'énergie électrostatique s'appelle
fono folle yom une installation hybride
qui fait partie des quatre oeuvres de
l'exposition scenocosme installé aux
prises miles en cours
des créations singulières qui ont toutes
un dénominateur commun
nous explorons beaucoup la question de
toucher de la relation à l'eau de la
relation à l'élément naturel dans toutes
nos installations interactives la place
du corps est toujours très importante et
nous interrogeons en fait nos relations
contemporaines
aujourd'hui avec ses différents
environnements et également nous
interroge aussi la place de la
technologie dans notre environnement
naturel et social de quelle manière nous
vivons avec un univers visuel et sonore
dans lequel vous pouvez notamment créé
en temps réel des mises en scènes
narratives
rencontre imaginaire est une série de
plusieurs oeuvres vidéo interactive
comportementale light contact met en
scène le corps et la peau des
spectateurs
[Musique]
lorsqu'une première personne pose la
main sur la bible se passe rien elle
doit aller venir toucher une deuxième
personne pour rendre entendre un son et
prouver une lumière qui va varier en
fonction de l'intensité énergétique de
cette relation c'est une troisième
personne quatrième personne vient se
rajouter à cette chaîne humaine leçon va
aussi se modifier bien que présentes
dans toutes ses installations la
technologie n'est jamais visibles les
expériences proposées par scenocosme
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 21 février
l'association plaisir oise un temps de
poètes organisera les 1er et 2 février
une exposition à la salle béjart
depuis 2008 la quarantaine d'adhérents
qui la composent font la promotion de la
poésie et de l'art en général
une trentaine d'artistes exposeront
leurs oeuvres lors de la manifestation
on a des poètes peintres on a des poètes
ce photographe banc donc c'est parti de
là l'idée qu'on pouvait peut-être
organiser ce type pour faire connaître
ses talents là cette expo du 1er et 2
février on l'a appelée har à tous les
étages une façon de parler puisque le
local la salle et sur deux niveaux mais
aussi à tous les étages c'est à dire
presque une universalité
on va parler d'art contemporain
puisqu'il est à l'honneur du 21 au 26
janvier au carré à la farine à
versailles
plus de 100 oeuvres sont à découvrir à
l'occasion de la 4e but
versailles est ce reportage
c'est un rendez-vous bien connu des
amateurs d'art contemporain la 4e
biennale versaillaise a pris place
pendant près d'une semaine au sein des
murs du carré à la farine le salon
regroupe plusieurs artistes de tous les
horizons
cette année ils sont soixante dix huit
venus de france mais aussi de belgique à
exposer leurs oeuvres
je fréquente les salons de la région
parisienne des paris les grands salons
d'art gérés par des artistes et j'envoie
des candidatures il se présente ainsi
comme plusieurs autres et là dans cette
biennale et l'a1 sordo qui ont été reçus
des représentations artistiques issues
de différents courants tableaux
sculptures gravures au total plus de 140
oeuvres font partie de cette édition
[Musique]
maman
pour les tableaux différents matériaux
ont été utilisés acrylique aquarelle ou
encore peinture à l'huile que j'ai c'est
de placer les tableaux -selon les thèmes
qu'ils ont utilisés selon les dimensions
les couleurs pour qu'ils se soient
harmonieuses techniquement des oeuvres à
découvrir et pourquoi pas acquérir
jusqu'au 26 janvier au carré à la farine
à versailles du théâtre à présent avec
le théâtre de but qui accueillera du 31
janvier au 8 février les 11e rencontres
théâtrales
au programme six représentations pour
les petits comme pour les plus grands
des textes classiques des auteurs
contemporains mais aussi des créations
plus d'informations sur le site qui
s'affiche à côté de moi
trois colocataires deux voisins une
application en de rencontrer de nombreux
problèmes voici comment on pourrait
résumer la pièce de théâtre un match à
domicile
particularité elle les comédiens sont
des étudiants de l'école d'ingénieurs de
l'estaca nous avons pu assister à l'une
de leurs répétitions
[Musique]
une relation adultère voici le point de
départ de la pièce match à domicile
les comédiens sont tous des étudiants de
l'estaca une école basée à montigny le
bretonneux qui forme des ingénieurs dans
le secteur des transports
un univers un peu éloigné d'une scène de
théâtre
moi j'en ai fait j'ai commencé quand
j'étais petit j'avais 10 ans et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a toujours passionné
qui m'a toujours plus de pouvoir
m'exprimer autrement
et donc voilà j'ai voulu continuer parce
que ça me fait sortir des cours et de
thé mathématiques etc
ce club théâtre est subventionné à
hauteur de 1400 euros par l'école au
cours de l'année des cours ont lieu avec
des metteurs en scène professionnels
parmi les grands projets cette pièce
écrite par l'un des étudiants jean
baptiste aubert le sujet il est moderne
c'est sur les applications de rencontres
simples et une parodie de pin de kinder
puis qui s'appelle pender dans la pièce
justement mais on a essayé de traiter ça
de façon assez classique quand même avec
des voiles à des équipes rocco est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire une sorte de
vaudeville moderne dont matches à
domicile on retrouve les codes du
théâtre classique un mari trompé des
voisins qui débarque sans prévenir des
quiproquos
sur scène sept comédiens répètent depuis
septembre au minimum une fois par
semaine après les cours
jeux pierrick qui est un peu en voisin
très très gentil on va dire ça qui a
tendance à créer sur ses colocataires
qui a tendance à créer chez sa voisine
sur son voisin du dessus qui déteste sa
mère est bon globalement une même
personne c'est quelqu'un antipathique et
c'est la pire personne qui puisse
exister je pense
l'unique représentation de cette pièce
made in estaca aura lieu le jeudi 30
janvier à 18 heures dans l'auditorium
elle est ouverte à tous
autre histoire d'amour à découvrir cette
fois ci sur grand écran je ne rêve que
de vous un film qui évoque notamment la
relation entre jeanne et léon blum
il sera projeté le mardi et 28 janvier à
20 heures à la salle du vieux marché à
jouy en josas une projection en présence
de l'équipe du film avec notamment
l'actrice elsa zylberstein pour pré
étape 10 euros c'est vrai ce qu'on
raconte sur ses rapports avec léon blum
se serait prête à tout laisser tomber
pour suivre un vieux politicards n'en
fait qu'à sa tête
des fêtes qui se prépare à être terrible
derome la faire payer très cher
la police a cerné la propriété du
monteur elles ont été monsieur blum
changement d'univers avec ce spectacle
de percussions le 31 janvier au théâtre
alphonse daudet de coignières accroc
percu met en scène quatre comédiens
musiciens
cette troupe belge détourne les objets
de leur fonction première au programme a
par exemple du haka sur une grosse
caisse symphonique ou encore un concerto
pour brosse à dents mais à la base
technique professionnel donc on a une
formation de musiciens classiques donc
on travaille sur des grottes et un pique
nique un marimba des carottes un plein
de choses qui sont dépêchés en classique
et puis il ya une deuxième chose de là
la partie plus créatives on va dire des
trop perçus
il détourne les objets du quotidien
comme un logo comme des brosses ya deux
rangs par un spectacle on a voulu
complètement international public donc
on n'a pas de langage à proprement
parler picquenot la musique et le milan
ce n est alors ya effectivement ce qu'on
peut retrouver dans ton nom ton
spectacle une double lecture du conduite
vraiment tout le monde
le 30 janvier le chanteur corneille sera
sur la scène de l'espace julien green à
andrésy à 17 ans après avoir été révélée
au grand public avec parce qu'on vient
de loin il revient avec son huitième
album parce qu'on aime wafou un stress
[Musique]
c'est comme un frère
mais ce tour de table
on était de prière
en effet désigné
et comme 3
on reste dans l'univers de la chanson
qui reportera la cinquième saison du
tremplin des voix à magny les hameaux et
d'heures pour le savoir rendez vous le
samedi 1er février à partir de 20h à la
maison de l'environnement sur scène 20
candidats parmi les 150 auditionné un
spectacle qui se veut interactif puisque
vous pourrez voter pour votre candidat
préféré
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
avant de se quitter vous le savez comme
chaque semaine niveau d'eau non ait des
idées de sorties le soir à saint quentin
en yvelines elle sachez que le prisme à
elancourt vous propose une soirée
chorégraphique le 28 janvier
du côté de la ferme de bel ébat
guyancourt il y aura de l'humour avec
tiphaine des le plus grand maître de la
métamorphose
arturo brachetti sera sur la scène de la
ferme d'une manne et enfin le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
trois représentations de la pièce
dramatique un ennemi du peuple
voici un avant-goût de ce qui vous
attend
[Musique]
alors mesdames qui vous permet parfois
de faire seules les tâches ménagères
parce que monsieur n'en fichent pas une
permettez moi de vous dire que vous
exagérez un parce que si vous pouvez
sifflé il est léger le ballet que ça va
vite quand la musique vous aide à
travailler
on sent que le mec qui a écrit ça y
passait pas souvent l'aspirateur
[Musique]
on y constate la présence de matières
organiques en décomposition des
bactéries à profusion cette eau est
absolument nocives pour la santé que ce
soit pour un usage interne ou externe
voilà c'est la forme de ce numéro merci
à tous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
10 prochain pour un nouveau numéro du
simply culture
[Musique]
m